hi there was a very famous book called  seven habits of successful people and  one of the important habits there was to  start out with the final goal in mind  now your goal is to become a fluent  speaker of whatever language you're  learning so you have to believe you can  do it you have to have that vision the  vision of the enjoyment that you will  have once you can watch movies in your  favorite language read books talk to  people travel of the country so every so  often again remind yourself of why  you're learning the language and that  the goal is to all of a sudden find  yourself as a new person someone who is  capable and I've done it on a number of  occasions you sometimes you think you'll  never get there but you got to keep that  goal fresh in your mind you're going to  become a fluent speaker of another  language keep your goal in mind good  luck